《红楼梦》里秦可轻的细分被删去了许多,这是读者间共识。但其实结合各个版本的批语,我们几乎能推断出删去多少页,为什么要删除,以及删除的具体内容都是什么。
以论来,这些内容里包含了假真、金融、秦周、甚至史乡云的文字。
为什么要删除秦可轻死去过程的描写,进藏本石头记第13回开篇,有一长短回前批语,写到是,
此回可轻梦阿奋,作者大有生意,习以为莫是耐何耐何,假真虽摄影,起能义复载,特因近老不管然后资议,足为世家之间,秦可轻营赏天乡楼,作者用识笔也。
老球因有魂脱奉劫,假家后是二件,起事安复遵容,作小人能想的到处。
其事虽未行,其言其意,令人悲借敢服,孤设置,一命情细删去,一三更于诸文,是以此回止时夜,删去天乡楼一节,少去四五夜野。
透过这段批语,我们可以得知。
草血秦对秦可轻的经历宿舟原本是完善的。后来在批数人的建议下,删去了秦可轻去世过程的具体描写。
原因是,秦可轻临终脱梦给奉劫,为假家未来担经结律,即便他和假真犯了爬回的禁忌,也需要得给这位金差留些体面。
以十头记,更成手抄本的新闻规范,一夜有十行左右文字,每行大约在三十字左右,那么草血秦删去的四五夜,大概有一千二至一千五百字,真可为是大山特山。
那么,秦可轻的文字究竟被删除了哪些,有一点是可以确定的,那就是秦可轻一定不是正常病事。
批输人名言,秦可轻知死乃是隐藏天乡楼,而且第五回,家寶玉梦入太虚幻境,看到秦可轻的叛化上化的是,一位美人悬良自议。
就算秦可轻生前生过病,但最终导致他相消遇云的具体原因,一定还是自议这条线索。
正如刚成本石头记,回莫批语所言,通回将可轻如何死故隐去,是大发辞微心眼。
草血秦虽然山的干净,好在批语街流存下来,能帮助我们读者得知可轻知死的群梦。
导致秦可轻知死的第一位嫌疑人,便是宁福老奴交大,其中原因不必多言,诸君自然知小。
第七回,交大最骂一节,已成红楼经典明场面。
交大九后诗言,大骂宁国府内存在,爬灰养小书子的现象,集中爬灰指的是公共和儿戏游染,自然指的是假身和亲可轻,这一点确认无疑,而这恰恰是亲可轻知死的源头。
蒙福本石头记第七回,回莫批语就评价道。
交大之罪,福可轻知病知死,周父之谈,事力之海真凶,作者具不提心,与世人说法。
亲可轻的病,就从交大这一骂开始,最骂当天,您容梁福皆有主子在场,几乎闹得人人皆知,甚至连后来的史乡云都知道了。
蒙福本宗,家宝语问鳳姐什么是爬灰,朋友蒙测批写道,暗服后来史乡云之问。
可惜的是,史乡云问爬灰这个情节,今天的红楼梦里已经看不到了,自然是被曹雪琴删干净了。
甚至我们无法确定,史乡云问爬灰发生在亲可轻自意之前,还是自意之后?
是否史乡云的这一问,也是导致亲可轻修分自意的原因之一,这还以有待继续考证。
交大最骂是开端,爬灰的舆论还在一直发酵,而且传到了假家学堂里。
亲可轻的弟弟情中,在假家学堂上学,因和金融闹出矛盾,引发了第九回,其嫌疑丸童闹学堂的风波。
我们读者,也往往将这场风波,当作小孩子间的炒闹,实责不染。
在闹学堂这场风波里,亲可轻的爬灰,似乎也被金融拿出来,当成攻击情中的工具。
诸君请看第十回,金寡父堪利全受辱,假黄之妻要为职质金融讨个公道,就来到宁国府找亲可轻。
却得知可轻重病握床,游氏变疆,秦英中和秦可轻的对话告诉了这位黄娜奶奶,援助季。
游氏说道,偏偏今日早晨她兄弟来瞧她,谁知那小孩子家不知好歹,看见她姐姐身上不大爽快,就有事也不当告诉她,别说是这么一点子小事。
就是你受了一万分的委屈,也不该想她说才是,谁知她们组织学房里打架,不知是哪里副学来的一个人欺辱了她了,里头还有些不甘不敬的话,都告诉了她姐姐。
学堂里那些不甘不敬的话,并不单止金融和明烟对骂时,所说的那些涉及升职器官的脏颜会语,也不及到了秦可轻的身上。
这一点证据很充分,蒙福本地时回,有回莫总批评道。
预速可轻之死,故先有恶奴之凶碗,而后极以秦中来告,层层课入,点录其用心过荡,种种文章逼指,
所以评语得居富士,诸凡随心,终有不能不妖王之道。
我不知作者与卓比时,何等妙心绣口,能到此无爱罚语,令人不惊眼花遥乱。
此处的恶奴之凶碗,指的是交大,不公君处独此处还有一些怀疑。
毕竟交大最骂,点破宁福祕士,更像是个老奋亲,趁不上恶奴,但读之后文可轻并试,
假真如散烤笔,称要尽其所有未可轻半桑里,
黄幼有一句蒙福本批语写道,进我所有为媳妇是非理之谈,父母又将何以待之,
故前此有恶奴酒后狂言,极竟附建此语含而不漏,无不能为假真隐悔。
此处恶奴酒后狂言六字,明点交大最骂,
显然批输人的情感更轻强于可轻,对于害死可轻的交大,便以恶奴平止。
可轻知死先有恶奴之凶碗,在友情中来告,层层课入。
如果轻终说的仅仅是学堂中的繁星式,就可轻知死而言,并不能达到层层课入的效果,
毕竟跟可轻自己无关。
真实的情况只能是,学堂内也流传了一些关于情可轻的消息。
爬回之以论风波已然发酵,借由弟弟秦忠传到可轻耳中,
将他的心理防险进一步激破,甚至有可能其父秦也也知晓了爬回的是,
在自家人面前失了尊严,这无疑试格巨大打击。
这些细节都为可轻的自尽埋下扶笔。
后来又发生了被草血秦删掉的一专更一文字。
直接促成了秦可轻读上天相楼,选择自义的方式结束自己的生命。
至于一专更一,具体指的是什么故事,我们无法得出准确答案。
但不红军个人感觉,假真秦可轻的相关文字,应接近金平之风。
只逼本红楼里也经常提到,红楼一书深得金平湖澳。
在金平梅里,有一个情节跟一专很像,
那便是第23回,居藏春潘氏潜松。
西门庆和普人之气送会连丝混,两人在藏春物大型云语之欢。
潘金连躲在暗处偷听两人说话,
听到宋惠连说自己是录水夫妻,经连大怒,
又不便闯进去,便拔下头上一根银沾,悄悄把门卡住。
四日睡醒,宋惠连推门不开,打吃一惊,
只得让西门庆叫来压缓开门,看见门上插着一根银沾,
宋惠连便知道,左晚的话都被潘金连听去了。
于是一斗重生,只得去潘金连房里,好言奉扯,
试探起心意。当然,草血巾未必会照超金屏美,
但既有可能借借相关的故事模式,
尤其红楼和金屏在许多细节方面简直神似。
故而,潘氏潜宗的故事,可能帮助我们了解遗咱的内涵,
至少可以提供一个可能性,尽管他未必准确。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。